[MUSIC PLAYING]
JEAN-PHILIPPE MARTIN: My
name is Jean-Philippe Martin.
I'm a senior software engineer
at Verily Life Science.
And today we'll be
talking about things
I worked on our genomic
pipeline with Apache Beam.
So the idea for
today's talk is I'll
start by giving you the
background, because it's
about reading DNA, or
sequencing DNA as we call it.
I'll tell you about the little
problem that we'll talk about
today, the tools that we have to
solve it-- this is going to be,
of course, Apache Beam--
how we solved it, and then,
we will spend a few slides
showing how well it worked.
All right.
So let's get started.
DNA, all right, we all have DNA.
It's in every cell in our body.
We get it from our parents.
We have one from each parent.
It's-- we write it as a
long string of letters.
It's 3 billion letters.
They're going to be A, C,
T, G. We have the technology
to read people's DNA.
I wouldn't say that we
know everything about it.
There's still a lot to learn.
If you take two
random people, you'll
find that they
differ in about 0.1%
of their genome, of their DNA.
So that's about three
million letters.
And DNA is particularly
interesting,
because one of the reasons is
that the cost has gone down
a lot.
You may have seen
this graph before
if you've gone to any talk about
sequencing DNA or reading DNA.
But we'll go through it quickly.
So the x-axis is time.
The y-axis is cost.
This is a logarithmic scale.
The green line is the
cost of reading the DNA.
And as you can see,
it has crashed.
The comparison line in
white is Moore's Law,
so it has-- the
price has gone down
even faster than Moore's Law.
And so now, it
costs roughly $1,000
to sequence somebody's DNA.
So this is fantastic.
And this means that we do
it a lot more than before,
because now it's cheaper.
Reading DNA is really nice
for a number of reasons.
It's not just about
reading the genome,
and understanding the
ancestry, and figuring out
the ways in which
people are different.
You could also sequence
somebody's cancer tumor
to try to find which
medicine are going to work.
You can also do other
things than reading DNA,
using the exact same technology.
So one of the things
that people do
is they read the RNA that
is active in the cells,
as they're creating proteins.
So what this does is that,
whereas the DNA is mostly
static if you're healthy,
so you get your DNA
and then that's what it is.
It determines the
blueprints of your body.
Reading the RNA tells you
what this particular cell is
doing at this particular time.
So this is something that you
can explore different tissues,
different places in
your body that are going
to be doing different things.
And then at different
times, it may
be doing different things,
perhaps healthy versus sick.
And you do this using the
exact same technology.
So the price, the
crashing of price,
means that we can now do this
RNA reading also very cheaply.
Another thing that
people do is you can,
because this instrument
works so well,
we use it to measure
other things.
So we use DNA sequencing
to find proteins.
So the way this works,
just briefly, is we can--
and by we I mean the field--
we can engineer and,
hopefully I get this right.
I'm a computer scientist, right?
So we can engineer an
antibody that will attach
to this particular protein.
And we can attach
a bit of DNA to it.
So what we do is we just
mix this in the blood,
or whatever we
are interested in.
And then we sequence this.
We wash it.
We wash the remaining liquid
off, and then we sequence it.
And so if that particular
protein was there,
then the antibody
attached to it.
And that we will find the
DNA that we're looking for.
So we can-- you can
read DNA in order
to find proteins or things
that are completely,
that are not directly
related to people's DNA.
OK.
So this is why I'm very
excited about reading DNA.
The point I wanted
to make here also
is that the cost of doing the
lab part has gone down a lot.
And in comparison,
the cost of doing
the computer part,
the analysis part,
has not gone down as much.
So in relative terms,
the computation
is now more important.
And so you want to spend a
little bit of effort trying to,
perhaps, make it go faster,
or cheaper, depending
on what you're optimizing for.
And this is
amplified by the fact
that we now have even more
data than before, because it's
cheap, so we do it more.
So we want to do-- so
computation is relatively more
expensive.
And there's also more of it.
So we'll be talking
about some computation.
So now, let me tell
you a little bit
about how reading
DNA works, just
so I can motivate the problem
that we're trying to solve.
So a typical lab would receive
perhaps 100,000 samples a year.
And the sample would be
perhaps a vial of blood.
It could be other things.
And the first
thing you do is you
try to extract
the DNA from this,
and amplify it, get a
higher concentration of DNA.
Perhaps you'll have 10 times
as much as you started from.
And then, we cut it
into tiny fragments.
And this is because the machines
can only read short bits of DNA
at all.
So we need to cut
it, so the machine
can access these parts--
a lot of fragments really,
perhaps 100 million
fragments in this example.
And so DNA, by the
way, has a direction,
so we don't worry too much
about it flipping around.
And then you put
it in the machine.
This is an example machine.
It doesn't have to be this one.
The machine is going to
read these fragments.
And there, some
things can go wrong.
These machines are not perfect.
So one of the things that
can go wrong is duplicates.
So bits of DNA can
show up in the output
as if they were there twice
as much as they really
are in the sample.
And this is the
problem that we're
going to work on in this talk.
So one of the reasons
this can happen
is there is an optical
part in this process.
So the picture here
symbolizes a bit of DNA.
And on the top are
the reads, so you
recognize these are the letters
I told you comprise DNA.
And if the thing is a
little bit out of focus,
it's possible that instead
of seeing one dot of light,
it thinks there are two dots.
And so that would mean
that each one of these
now shows up twice
in the output.
And this can happen, you know
as much as for 25% of the reads.
So it's significant.
And it's a problem.
Because when you
do the analysis,
you really care about
the relative ratio
of each particular bit of DNA.
And so if these ratios are out
of whack because of errors,
your analysis may be wrong,
or slightly off target.
So we want to detect these
duplicates and remove them,
so that we can restore the
independence assumption that
underlies some of
the analysis that you
want to run downstream.
Now, for the context here is
how the rest of the bits happen.
So the first image
here is in the machine.
So remember, we cut the DNA
into these small fragments.
Then, the machine
is going to read
from each end of the
fragment, going inwards.
And it can only read
roughly 100 bases down.
And so they won't
actually make--
they won't meet in the middle.
They will just
read a little bit,
and then the
machine has to stop.
So you have these
two reads, that we
know they're close to
each other in the genome.
And so we say that
they're a pair.
They go together.
And, of course,
then we flip them
so they are at the right spot.
So the green box onward is what
happens outside of the machine.
This is now part of
the computer stuff.
And so the first thing we do
is we flip them right side up.
And then, based on the
letters that we see,
we are going to-- there's of
course more letters than are
just shown on the slide.
We're going to compare this
to the reference genome,
and figure out
where in the genome
this particular read should be.
So this read's represented by
the number here on the left.
And you see the dotted line.
So the first one
starts at position 100.
Of course, we'd also say
which chromosome it's at.
Here, I'm simplifying
for the talk.
So you have the
position for each.
And then, because we
multiplied, we amplify the DNA
at the first stage, you don't
have just one strand of DNA
in there.
So it's possible
that they overlap.
And so you can use this
overlap to perhaps find errors.
So one of the errors that the
machine can do-- we already
talked about duplication.
Another error they
can make is just
misread one of the letters.
So perhaps you have two reads
like the two on the left
here in the red
box that overlap.
And then you would expect
the letters to be the same.
And in this case, there is one
place where they're different.
So this could be because
it's one from the father, one
for the mother.
Or it could be because
there was a reading error.
And so if you have multiple
reads that overlap,
and you have removed
the duplicates,
then you can perhaps use
majority rule, or something
like this, to figure out
what's the reality there
and which part was an error.
So this is an example where
removing the duplicates
matters.
And yes so a file like this
may be 50 gigabytes or so,
just to give you an
idea of the scale.
So what this looks like in
the computer, on the top
I have the symbolic
representation.
You have the helix of the DNA.
And you have the
reads that we found.
So on the computer,
from our point of view
here today it's just a record
with these four fields.
And importantly,
if two reads come
from the same fragment
of DNA, so they're both
read from different ends of
the same fragment of DNA,
we say that they're paired.
And we're going to give
them the same name.
This is how we know
they go together.
And there is a paired flag
that we're going to set to yes,
so that we remember
that these go together.
I represent them
with warmer colors
for the reads that are
paired and a cooler color
for the reads that are not.
But you don't need
to remember this.
All right.
So here's the takeaway
from the biology.
So you don't need to
remember the biology.
But all that really matters
from the point of view
of the computation
we'll be talking about
is that the data
structure we work with
is a set of read records.
And these read records
have the fields that
are here on the screen.
Importantly, they have a name,
a pair flag and a position.
And if two reads
have the same name,
that means that they are paired.
And their paired file is
going to be set to yes.
The task is to set the flag
that's circled here called
is duplicate, because we're
looking for the duplicates.
I will tell you in
the next slide what
are the rules for doing this.
And the output is
of the same form.
It's a set of
records, but now we
filled in this form, this field.
All right.
So the rules, now this slide
looks a little bit busy,
but bear with me.
This is actually fairly simple.
We're comparing reads.
Now, they can be paired or not.
So there's three cases.
Either they're both unpaired,
or both paired, or one of each.
We'll do each case at a time.
They're just the different rows.
So the first case is
unpaired, so suppose
you have two unpaired reads.
The rule that we use
is simply, if they
both have the same
position, then
we say they are duplicates.
And we're going to
mark one of them.
And I represent this in the
example in the middle column.
You can see the green
and blue reads here.
I aligned them to the
same horizontal position.
I'm using this to symbolically
represent the fact that they
have the same position
in the genome,
so their position field
has the same value.
So they're duplicates.
And so I circle one that we're
going to mark as duplicate.
The column on the right shows
an example of a non-duplicate.
They're offset.
They don't have
the same position.
So we don't mark them.
Now for pairs, the
middle row, the rule
is that both
positions must match.
So if you have paired reads,
if you have two pairs,
then the position of
each element of the pair
must match with the
corresponding element
from the other pair.
So you can see in
the example here,
I have a green pair
and a orange pair.
And they must align on
the left and on the right.
On the other, the
counter-example on the right,
you can see if any one
of them is offset then
we don't mark anything.
The final case is mixed.
If you have one paired
read and one unpaired read,
then it's only the unpaired
read that's going to get marked.
And it's going to be marked if
it's position matches either
of the elements of the pair.
So it's always kind
of the same rule.
It's just, if there's
only one position,
it's the position must match.
You have two positions,
both positions must match.
And if it's a mix, one of
the positions must match.
So that's the rule that
we have to implement.
And now, before we start
talking about tool,
I want to give you just a
quick overview of the landscape
of things that you could use.
This is very high
level, and it's
kind of my own way
of thinking of it.
So the way I think of it is
on the one hand on the left,
you have what I'm calling
servers as a service.
This is where you use the
cloud just to rent the computer
and run your thing on it.
And so you can take an existing
program and just put it there.
And it'll work just fine.
This is the easiest thing to
do because it's very familiar.
And so this is great.
For example, if you already have
some existing legacy already
written software, you can
just run it there as is.
You would perhaps use
a tool like Kubernetes.
In life science, we have
developed our own tools.
There is Cromwell.
At Verily, we put together
a dsub, which is an--
it's for our users.
It's a simple tool for
running things on the cloud,
on the server.
Or you may want to go
a little bit further
down the abstraction
route and use
what I'm calling a
database-centric approach,
where you use a database
abstraction that the cloud can
give you, such as BigQuery.
And so here, this is great when
your data is mostly static.
Perhaps you've already
done the analysis,
now you just want to
present it in a fancy way.
And you want to be able to
have multiple computers serving
the data, so lots of people can
go and look at your results.
And the one on the right
is pushing the abstraction
a little bit further.
Now, that's the
data flow languages.
So the data flow
languages allow you
to get a lot of parallelism.
And the idea here
is that we're now
representing your
computation-- this
is for your computation--
we're representing it
as a graph, where the nodes
represent things that happen
to the data, so computation.
And the edges represent
the data flowing,
that's why we call them
a data flow language.
So in this example
picture here, we
have three different things
that happen to the data.
And the data flows
from one to the other.
And there are multiple
such languages.
There's Apache Beam,
that we'll talk about.
You may have heard
of Spark also.
So you get parallelism,
because each
of these three steps
here in the picture
can be done at the same time.
Each of these are maybe
different computers
running at the same time.
And also each
individual step can
be done in cooperative
manner, by multiple computers.
So let's give you the
punchline of the talk already.
So we started from a
non-optimized single server
running this thing.
And then we wanted to
write it with Beam.
And we did.
And the result is five times
faster at only twice the cost.
So we're pretty happy
with the result.
But let's see how we did this.
Why did we choose Apache Beam?
Apache Beam is good
when you're working
on a large set of elements
that are all of the same type.
This is the case here
with the genomics read.
We have a large number of them.
We can process them in parallel.
This is a common
pattern in life science.
And you may recognize the same
pattern in your own field.
You know, it's not uncommon to
have many receipts, or images,
or purchases, or
clicks, or views,
or ad impressions,
things like that.
The best way I know to explain
Beam is through an example.
So we'll just jump right in.
So suppose what you're
trying to do is--
so still in the genomic context
that we're talking about--
suppose we want to know, for
each position in the genome,
how many reads do we have
at that particular position?
So in the example here,
we go from left to right.
On the left we have storage
with our set of reads.
There are two blue
reads at position 12
and a red read at position 20.
So the way you do
this with Beam is you
would start by
grouping by position.
So group by would
put elements together
that match the thing
that you specify.
So position in this
case, so you end up
with two groups, a
group at position 12,
a group at position 20.
And the next step you
would do is you would say,
now I want to count how many
elements are in each group.
And so you get your answer.
At position 12,
I have two reads.
At position 20, I have one.
We're done.
That's what it looks like.
It's a very simple
example, of course.
But at least I didn't
give you word count.
Now, this is the
abstraction, right?
So what happens when
you run this in Beam
is that your code
remains simple.
So your code is--
I put pseudocode
here on the left.
It matches these
simple concepts.
But the runtime can actually
leverage the simple description
to give you parallelism.
So you saw where, whereas
before we had one yellow
dot representing
one computation.
When you hit Run, it ends
up being multiple machines.
I put two on the
slide for space.
So what can happen
is the compiler
recognizes that
you're trying to do
an operation on every element.
This can be done in parallel.
So let's do it.
It recognizes ah, you're reading
these files from the cloud.
Well, it so happens that
the cloud replicates files
for availabilities,
so we can actually
read from different replicas
to get more performance.
And it will do all of these
things for you transparently.
One cool thing it can
do also is actually
it can watch your
computation as it goes,
and potentially add or remove
computers to tune things
as it's going.
So I wanted to say, in case
you're familiar with MapReduce,
this may look very
familiar to you.
And so indeed, Apache
Beam is actually,
it's a generalization
of MapReduce.
So in the sample example,
it looks the same.
But Beam differs in,
I would say, two ways.
The first is that
instead of just being
one map and one reduce, you can
do an arbitrary number of these
together in the same
program, without having
to do anything special.
So it doesn't have
to be two steps.
And the other difference is it
has more operations than just
these two.
So let's go through some of the
operations that Beam can do.
So here is an
example Beam program.
It's a graph.
They all look like graphs.
This program is
completely artificial.
It's just there to show
the different things
that Beam can do.
So the first computation
here, marked A,
I wanted to show
that Beam can have
multiple inputs coming
into the same computation,
and multiple outputs.
So you're not limited
to simple graphs.
And when you send
to multiple places,
it could be you send the
same data to everybody.
You have different
sub-computations
that you need to do
in the same input.
Or perhaps, you send
different subsets of your data
to different sub-computations.
Perhaps, I don't know,
all the green images
do some-- get some processing.
And all the blue images
processed in a different way.
So that's multiple
inputs and outputs.
The next dot, the B circle
here shows the map operation.
You apply an arbitrary
function to each element.
So in the picture here,
I'm just bolding them.
Of course, you can write
arbitrary code, you
just, whatever code you like
to process the elements.
And when you put
this in Beam, you
will know to put it
on multiple computers
and apply this to all the
elements in your collection.
You can also add or remove
elements from a collection.
So this is the next dot here.
You see I've added the Pac-Man
shape and removed another.
The next one, D, is combining.
Here, I'm showing
just the count.
So we have three shapes.
And I get the count.
There's a number of
built-in combiners.
You can do a max.
You can do a sum,
minimum obviously.
But the neat thing is actually
you can write your own.
So any piece of
code, so long as it's
associative and
commutative, the Beam
will know how to
run it efficiently
on multiple machines, and run
a little computation tree,
aggregation tree, and get you
the right answer efficiently.
And you don't need to do
anything, you just specify
the aggregation function.
The final one on this slide,
there's actually more,
but the final one here we're
talking about is group by.
You've seen group
by before, where
we're grouping by a position.
So it takes a set of
elements and it gives you
a set of groups of elements.
Group by in Beam actually has
another really nice feature
that I just want to mention
now, even though we're not
using here, is that Apache Beam
can run in a streaming mode.
So instead, whereas in a
normal, usual computation
you have some input.
And you run it on your program.
And you get an output,
and you're done.
In a streaming
computation, the program
just keeps on running
forever, conceptually.
And you have inputs
coming in as streaming in,
perhaps they're publish
subscribes, events, or clicks,
or things happen in the world.
And then your program
computes things,
and they spit out
the back continually.
So you can group by for this.
You can group by
time window, so you
can get like a daily
summary or something.
Or you can also group by
and get a sliding window,
so you know the number of
sales in the past 10 minutes
or whatever, things like this.
OK.
So this is the overview
of what Beam can do.
There is more.
But hopefully this gives you
a good taste and a good idea
of what it can do.
And when you write
Beam, you can write it
in actually multiple languages.
You can have your choice.
There's Java, Scala,
Python, or Go.
And I used the Python.
And here's what the sample
program looks like in Python.
It's fairly straightforward.
The one thing to notice is that
the group by is now two lines.
What happens is group by
doesn't take arguments, instead
what you do is you write
your data as a tuple,
where the first
element of the tuple
is what you want to group by.
And then you just call
group by, or group by key,
and it's going to group
by the first element.
So you write these two
lines to do your group by.
And you can see here the
file names start with gs.
That's a path for storage
on Google Cloud Storage.
So I could say a
lot more about Beam.
I just want to focus on
my favorite features.
And so the first one
here is that Beam
is a little bit
unique in the sense
that, when you write
a Beam program,
it can actually-- it will
actually kind of cross
compile it to different runners,
to different other distributed
systems.
So the one on the
left is not labeled.
But this is Google
Cloud Dataflow,
so you would use this
to run it on the Cloud.
You can also run it on
Apache Flink, or Spark,
or a number of other ones.
So this is great,
because this means
that you write the
same program, and you
could write-- you could run
it on your local cluster,
say using Spark.
Or you could run it
on a Google cluster,
using Google Cloud Dataflow.
Or you could run it on
somebody else's cluster,
using one of these
other systems.
And you know, if
one of these systems
developed some great innovation
and it becomes super fast,
you can just choose
to use this one.
So that's really nice.
The other thing is
the auto-scaling,
I already hinted at before.
So this graph shows this
kind of in a graphical way.
This is what you actually
see when you're running.
Here it was just a toy program.
But the idea is that it will add
and remove computers as needed.
So there are two lines here.
So you may be curious,
the green line
represents the
number of computers
that the system
decided was optimal.
And the blue line is the number
of computers that were actually
running at the time.
So you can see the blue
line just kind of quickly
matches up to the green line.
It just takes a
little bit of time
to start and stop the computers.
And you can see this particular
computation, you know,
it has multiple phases.
There is some sort
of, perhaps, setup
at the beginning, where you have
a small number of computers.
And then the
computation ramps up
and the system adds
machines as needed.
And it looks like there is a
third phase at the end, where
we're doing something else
that doesn't need quite as
many machines.
And so they quickly cut down
the number of computers.
This is done automatically.
All you have to do is
enable auto-scaling
and then you can just
see what happens.
The third thing I wanted to
highlight about Apache Beam
is the many connection options.
So I already
mentioned that you can
read from a file
on the Google Cloud
with Google Cloud Storage.
You can also read from
other people's clouds.
You can read from a database.
You can read events from a
published subscribe system.
You can even-- this would be for
the streaming case I mentioned
before--
you can even connect it to
another Dataflow language
that's going to be
streaming events at you.
So you can imagine running
Apache Kafka to get some events
streaming through the system.
And you, perhaps
for some reason,
already wrote this in Kafka.
Then you want to do some
additional processing
in Apache Beam.
Well, you can connect the two,
and the events flow through,
and now you can do your
streaming computation.
And when you're running Beam,
if you're running with Dataflow,
then this is what it looks like.
I know that the
picture is perhaps
too small to see the details.
But I just wanted to give
you an overview anyways.
So the biggest part
here on the left
is a graphical representation
of your program.
That's the one you gave in
when you type in your program,
Beam programs are graphs.
And each box is labeled with
the name that you gave it.
These are your functions.
And it gives you some
information about
whether it's running or
not and how fast and so on.
And on the right, you have
some overall statistics
about your job.
It tells you how many
computers are running it,
so that's the worker count.
It tells you how many resources
have been consumed so far.
Some options that you
specified on the command line
are repeated here.
And then, you have
the auto-scaling graph
in the middle that I
already explained before.
So as your computation
is running,
you can see how many
computers are assigned to it.
And you choose to use
auto-scaling scaling, or not.
If you don't, it's just
going to be a straight line.
So that's our quick
introduction to Apache Beam.
And hopefully, I made you want
to see more and learn more.
And now we'll go
through this example
of marking the duplicates
using Apache Beam,
so you can see what it
looks like in action.
So just a quick
reminder, right, we
have this set of read records.
And we want to mark--
we want to update the
is duplicate fields.
And the rule is that
if they are unpaired,
and in the same position,
we mark them as duplicate.
If they're paired and both
are in the same position,
and if they're a
mix, then if they're
any of the position matches,
we mark it as duplicate.
That's the rules.
Let's go.
So here's the first
Beam program to do this.
So our input on the left
is the set of read records.
And the first thing
we're going to do
is check whether
they're paired or not.
We have the paired
flag, then we're
going to send it to
the different branch.
So let's start with
the blue branch
at the bottom, where the case
where they're not paired.
So when the reads
are not paired,
we're going to use group by to
put together all the reads that
start at the same position.
So we're grouping by position.
And then we look at
each group and we look
at how many elements there are.
If there is more than
one, we found duplicates,
so we mark them.
And then we're done, goes
to the storage on the end,
so our output set of
read records again.
In the case where
they're paired,
we need to do a
little bit more work.
The first thing we do
is we group them by name
to put the pairs back together.
Remember, if two
reads are paired,
they have the same name.
So doing this we
get the pairs back.
Then once we have
the pairs, we group
the pairs by their position
tuple, so the position
of each half.
And if you have more than
one in the same group,
that means that both
of their positions
match, so they're duplicates.
So we mark them and we're done.
So this is, hopefully,
fairly reasonable.
I'll go through an example to
make sure that we're really
on the same page.
We'll start with the
unpaired read example.
So here we have three reads.
There is blue, green,
and the dark blue.
And the blue and dark blue
are both at position 100,
and the green one is at
a different position.
So we checked.
Yes, they are not paired,
so we go in the blue path.
And the first thing we do is
we group them by position.
So we end up with
these two groups here.
There's a group at position 100
and a group at position 400.
You can see that the first
group has more than one element.
These reads are duplicates.
So we are marking everyone,
except the first one,
representing this by
circling them in the picture.
This means we set
the field to true.
And we're done.
Now, in the case
of paired reads,
this time here I give you four
reads, two yellow, and two red.
The two yellow
have the same name.
They're paired to the
two red, likewise.
And their positions
are 100 and 400.
So the first thing we do
is we group them by name.
So you can see now, we put
the pairs back together.
So you have the yellow
pair and the red pair.
And if there were read
anymore, they would be there.
The next thing we do is
now we group by position.
So it so happens in this
example that both pairs
have the same positions,
they're at 100, 400.
So this group has
more than one element,
it means we found a duplicate.
We mark it.
We're done.
So this is great.
And it would work,
except that there
is a case we didn't go through.
You may have noticed this.
You may have been wondering
while I was presenting.
What about if we have reads
that are paired mixed with
reads that are unpaired?
There's a rule there that says
we have to mark some of them.
So we need to add this
for the program to work.
So let's fix the program.
So here is the
exact same program,
except now, I removed the
details from the boxes.
And I just put a
one-line description
of what each box does.
But it's the same program.
So the fix is the
following, you first
checked if the reads
are paired or not.
And then, you send all the
reads down the unpaired check.
Because when we have
the unpaired reads,
we need to mark
them as duplicates
if they match another unpaired
read, but also if they
match a paired read.
So we are kind of merging
the red and the blue paths
down here at the bottom.
That's way I put it in purple.
So now we can check the unpaired
read correctly and write them
down.
And the top part
remains, of course.
So the paired
reads, we still need
to put the pairs together and do
the processing and everything.
So this is the correct fix.
This would work.
I've run this.
But now, you may be
wondering, well, you know,
these paired reads are
going through both paths.
It looks like we're doing
some redundant computation.
Could we optimize
this a little bit?
You know, could we
change the program, such
that instead of sending all
the paired reads to check,
we perhaps eliminate some
paired reads that can't possibly
be duplicates in this
first purple step,
and then only send the
remainder to the red step,
instead of sending them all?
And, of course, the
reason I'm suggesting this
is that, yes, you can do it.
The key insight
here is, what can we
do when we only have
half of the pair?
So if they're
unpaired, of course,
we can do the whole thing.
In the example
here, right, I have
the green and the blue read.
I'm aligning them vertically
to represent the fact that they
have the same position.
These are duplicates.
If you have paired reads,
here, for example, the yellow
and orange, I put
the dotted line
to show that this is
half of a paired read.
We can see that these two
are the same position.
They're aligned.
But we don't know what happens
to the other half of the pair.
So we actually don't know
whether they're duplicates
or not.
They could be duplicates.
Or they could be non-duplicates.
At this point, we
really can't tell.
The orange read at
the bottom, instead,
this one we know it can't
possibly be a duplicate.
Because remember, the rule is
that both halves have to match,
right?
And at this position,
there is only one read.
So we know that, because
this half doesn't match,
it doesn't matter what
happens to the other half.
This particular read
cannot be a duplicate.
So we can eliminate it.
So that's the insight.
We only need to take the reads
that are in this middle case
and send them for
further processing
to double check if
they're paired or--
sorry, if they're
duplicates or not.
The rest, we're done.
And so just quickly here is
what the program looks like.
I know the slide
looks busy, but this
is very similar to the
program we've seen before,
worked through together before.
It's just vertical
because I had to fit it.
We start at the top left.
The reads come in.
We group them by position.
And once we have
this, we can correctly
mark all the unpaired
reads that are duplicates.
And then, what about
the paired reads?
Well, we look.
Is there more than one at
this particular location?
If there is more than
one, then we go, yes.
And the paired reads go to
the red path on the right.
So because these are
the ambiguous case.
If there's more than one,
they could be duplicate.
We don't know.
If there is one or fewer, than
everything goes to the output.
We're done with those.
And the right path is
the same as before.
You put the pairs together.
You check their positions.
If there's more than one
of the same position,
you mark them as duplicates.
We've seen this.
It works.
All right.
So just to make things
a little bit concrete,
here's what it looks
like in Python.
This is actual code taken
straight from my editor.
It's incomplete, of course.
The full program wouldn't fit.
But this is just
to give you a feel.
So the text that's bolded
is actually comments.
It's the name of the
stages of the boxes.
And so this is what the names
that will show up in the GUI.
And then, I call the code.
They're all in the
Beam namespace.
And you can see the way we do.
So here there's a
function I'm calling
keep only if has mapped mate.
So I only keep the paired reads.
And then, the step one
will put a key in it
that represents the name.
And so I'm grouping by name.
And then, I'm putting a key
that represents the positions.
And then I'm
grouping by position.
This is step four.
This is exactly as we
describe in the box.
Then, we mark the
duplicates, and we're done.
So, of course, we'll need
to fill in the functions.
There are plenty of
examples on the web.
But this is what this
particular program looks like.
And it gives you a flavor.
So there's one more
thing I did that I need
to mention for completeness.
By default, when you
run this on the cloud,
this is for Dataflow
flow in particular,
it will assign each worker
a 250 gigabytes disk.
Turns out for this work this
was more than necessary,
so I shrunk it to 85 disk.
So now we need less storage,
and so it's going to be cheaper.
And here are the results
of the optimization step.
So what I'm comparing here
is the original fixed program
that we've seen
in the talk that's
still running Beam, and then
the optimized Beam program.
So this is Apache
Beam on both sides.
This is just the impact
of these two optimizations
we did, first,
shrinking the disk size,
and second, the
algorithmic optimization
I walked you through.
And so what we can
see is that we're
43% cheaper, so almost half the
costs with these small changes.
A third of that
comes from shrinking
the disk, and another
2/3 from the optimization
that we walked through.
And the other thing
that I wanted to do
is compare this program
against our original program
that was running
on a single server.
So this single server
program was running off
the shelf software using
genomic libraries and stuff.
And I must emphasize it
wasn't particularly tuned
for performance.
And I'm comparing it to our
optimized Apache Beam program.
And of course, this is
our own versions, right.
I'm not making any promise
that the same thing
will happen to you if you
port your programs to Beam.
This is just what
happened to us.
And what happened to us is
we're five times faster,
5.6 times faster.
The cost also went up,
but it went up only 2x.
So I have this graphically
here on the slide.
The green bars show the
time, server on the left,
Apache Beam on the right.
So you can see the
time just crashed down.
And the cost on
the right in blue.
So again, server on the
left, the Beam version
is on the right, the
cost roughly doubled.
But the absolute numbers
are not that high.
So what I-- you know,
what's not in these--
we like to focus on
the numbers, right.
But another thing
that's really important,
perhaps even more important,
is that the program now
is a lot simpler.
Because this program
now just need
to focus on the business logic.
In our case, that is
marking the duplicates.
All the parallelization
and the distribution,
and the fault tolerance,
and all that stuff
is done by Beam and Dataflow.
We don't have to worry about it.
So this is something
that I really appreciate.
And then we have this other
side bonus, which is we
have now a trade-off
between speed and cost.
Because we can choose to
set the number of workers,
the number of computers,
that are running our program.
So these numbers I give
you are for 90 workers.
But you can also run it for
different numbers of workers.
So what I plotted here
is, so each dot represents
the average of five experiments
with a set number of computers.
So I went from 15
to 120 workers.
And I measured-- for each of
these I measured how much it
costs and how long it took.
So the x-axis is the cost.
That's kind of how
much you put in.
And the y-axis is the
runtime, so world clock,
so just measured overall.
So you want to be
kind of left and low.
And what you can see,
and this is actually
a very common pattern, is that
initially, as you add workers,
your performance
improves dramatically.
And your cost only
increases a little bit.
And that's because there
are parts of your program
that parallelize really well.
And so, as you double
the number of workers,
these parts take
only half the time.
And so now your program
is a lot faster.
In an extreme case,
you could imagine
that perhaps all of your
computation is like that.
And if that were
the case, then when
you double the
number of machines,
your running time
would completely halve.
And because you're
billed by the second,
your cost would be the same.
So you'd be putting
twice as many computers,
be going twice as fast,
for the same price.
So this is the ideal case.
Here, of course,
in reality, there's
a little bit of a slope.
And what you see is, as you
push this forward further,
as you put more and
more workers, now
the parts that parallelize
well are already
shrunk to a small
amount of time.
So they don't represent a large
part of the computation time.
And the remaining
parts, perhaps,
don't parallelize as well.
And so they're going to
be relatively larger part
of the time.
And so the curve flattens up.
That's what you see.
It starts out really steep.
And then it flattens.
At which point is
best for you really
depends on how much you
value time versus money.
This is a trade-off
that only you can make.
Another way of representing the
exact same data is as a ratio.
So you can look at how much
more expensive than the thing
we started from and
how much faster.
So here I put in red
the original program.
I started with the blue
dots are the same as before.
So every dot represents the
average of five experiments
for a given number of workers.
And so the dotted
line represents
kind of what you might
expect if you were taking
the original program
and just if you
were able to run
it on two machines
and get it twice as fast.
So the dotted line represents
this linear speed up of,
you know, if you
double the cost,
perhaps you'll get
twice the speed.
But, of course, in our case,
this is not the same program.
This is a completely
new program that
is written cloud-native
in Beam and has
different characteristics.
And so what we see
is that it shifts
kind of up and to the right.
It's more expensive
but much faster.
And as we add to the number
of workers, it goes up.
If I were to add more, I
expect this would flatten out.
I just didn't run the
experiments with more.
So that's what it looks like.
Just a few takeaways,
so, you know,
if you can remember just
one thing about Apache Beam,
is think of it as it's an
abstraction about how the data
flows through your computation.
And putting your
computation in these terms
allows it to get
really high degrees
of parallelism and performance.
This is really good when you're
computing with lots of data
items that are the same type.
This is a common
pattern in life science.
You may also see
it in your field.
The most common
operations are group by
and map or parallel do.
And so group by
will put together
elements that match in
some way that you specify.
And the other one
is when you want
to do an operation on
every element in a group,
or in the collection.
There is more. as you've seen.
Apache Beam is great when
you're writing a new program.
You can write your program
in this cloud-native way.
If instead you already have
a large amount of software
that you can't modify, you
want to run as is on the cloud,
perhaps you want to
use something else that
lets you just rent a computer
and run things there,
like Kubernetes, or our
very own dsub that's
an open source tool.
[MUSIC PLAYING]